well I'm Arnold cling and I write for
the blog econ log and over I left the
job over 10 years ago but I was a
economist at Freddie Mac so have that
perhaps dubious qualification
well that the answer depends on who you
ask clearly Ben Bernanke and henry
paulson think it's very bad and they are
much closer to the situation on Wall
Street than I am and I take their view
seriously on the other hand Alan Meltzer
who is the leading historian of central
bank in the United States thinks that
the they're exaggerating and the crisis
is overstated and certainly if you look
at the general economy the unemployment
rate is higher than it was a few years
ago but far far lower than in previous
recessions or it's certainly in the
Great Depression so I think that's a an
arguable question exactly how bad it is
in my opinion the proposed bailout plans
could hardly be worse I have two
perspectives on this first of all as a
libertarian this is a huge huge power
grab it really links tightly big finance
and big government and we should be very
opposed to that my other perspective is
I did mention that I was an economist at
Freddie Mac and at the time my focus was
on developing models of mortgage credit
risk and that's a sophisticated
difficult task and in my opinion what
has gone wrong in the last several years
is that a lot of people who don't
understand mortgage credit risk have
been taking mortgage credit risk and
Paulson and Bernanke for all their
knowledge and they know a lot more about
a lot of things than I do do not
understand mortgage credit risk and
nobody involved in pushing this plan
understands what they're getting into
and how difficult it will be to value
these mortgage securities they all just
assume that they can hire some technical
person someone like what I was 10 or 15
years ago to take care of it and is the
person who would be tasked for doing
this I'd say it's not possible to do it
the securities are too complex and
they're too sensitive to potential
scenarios for house prices they the core
task of this bailout is going to be
valuing these mortgage securities and
that is an impossible task and that the
bailout is bound to fail for that reason
it emphasized that none of the
modifications that are being talked
about to this plan whether the Dodd
modifications or what Paul Krugman might
propose make it any better you know
there's been a phrase used in this
political campaign that if you put
lipstick on a pig it's still a pig this
plot any plan that involves this much
involvement of government and finance
and linking them together is a pig no
matter what kind of lipstick you put
onto it
so am i concern that Congress has
seven days to go over it i don't know
whether I'd be more worried if they had
seven days or if they had 50 days the
way Paulson and Bernanke have positioned
it they have no negotiating leverage
whatever Congress adds to it Bernanke
and Paulson are saying we have to
approve sign the bill or it will be the
end of the world so Congress could add
whatever they want they could add
universal health care universal daycare
universal yoga classes I mean whatever
they want to add to this bill and the
bush will have to sign it or else he's
saying that he's committed to the end of
the world
what I what I've suggested as an
alternative is to modify capital
requirements one of the reasons that
financial markets have frozen up is that
banks or especially but other financial
institutions are but especially banks
are struggling to meet regulatory
capital requirements as the mortgage
assets get marked down to lower and
lower values if we were to loosen the
capital requirements they could continue
lending which is the alleged goal of the
Paulson bailout plan but we would not be
committed to trying to bail them out by
buying out these securities without
knowing what their value is their value
can be discovered over time in the
marketplace and if we loosen capital
requirements we're taking a risk that
some banks will fail and will have to
bail them out but that seems like a
smaller more manageable risk we have an
FDIC that's very experienced at
monitoring banks and trying to control
losses and so we'd be building on stuff
that we know that works rather than
spending seven hundred billion dollars
on an untried new business model